partly in South Yorkshire wants the
bustling center of Britain's coal
industry the kind of place the Labour
Heartland cliche was invented for but in
2011 a tremor was felt Jarvis
dan fourteen thousand seven hundred and
twenty four as expected labour won the
Barnes ik central by-election but you
kept came second for the first time in a
Westminster vote at the time it was
dismissed as a few Tories having a
flutter with the purple party they were
wrong and labour would pay for their
complacency the labor in the north of
England Barnsley was the canary in the
mind the place where you kept first
started performing well in the seat
previously dismissed as rock-solid and
it happened here the home of Arthur
Scargill the place that's obediently
returned a Labour MP in every election
since 1935 so balanced we see forgotten
and no that's that's really interesting
though it's interesting you know you
feel that politicians of Westminster
f-forget imbalance the people yeah I
think this needs to be more input into a
and I mean one time he used to be a
thriving town look what [ __ ] now
factories or what you call industry it
will fall you could get a job anywhere
but all over weird is it nerdy no
normally factually nothing so what did
he what she did you work in manufacture
in Barnsley I did for 37 years what same
company as a million Freeman's rubber
factory and we supplied basically
anything in rule of plastic do all of it
world now let's call it what I was the
job that you could good up and now
there's no work for anybody
things are short in and you know people
have just done red line all time I got
the key to the leader they've got down
but about what I've always voted me
what weren't is their keen on the leader
I don't you don't know what he's really
doing at the moment I'm not very happy
with the rebel party the infighting is
it's a bit too much I think they've got
a newly elected leader they should all
get behind him at this stage and give
him a chance we're just asking people to
use really on the labour party the
decline of industry has not only left
its mark on the landscape but the people
more than one in five children here are
living in poverty and it's hard to get
out Barnsley central is the second worst
constituency in the country for social
mobility in wards likes at Helens you
can understand why people are angry
child poverty here is double the
national average long-term unemployment
more than double but if Labour want to
change that they need to be in power
first it's a fact not lost on the local
MP on a visit to Dalton College to
promote his child poverty bill what are
the big issues that you're concerned
about what the big challenges you think
that that you face growing up
and at some point entering into the
world of work child poverty and maybe
maybe educating people help see
ourselves out of that situation
yes possible this week dan Jarvis will
introduce a private member's bill to try
and force the government to put a new
child poverty target in place after they
scrapped the old one it's about ensuring
that where you grow up doesn't determine
where you end up and I listened very
carefully to what the prime minister
said when she stood on the steps of
Downing Street and she said that she was
going to fight burning in Justices and I
think it's a burning justice that now
nearly 4 million children grow up in
poverty it's a burning justice that that
makes it much harder for them to get the
best possible education and a burning
injustice that it makes it much harder
for them to go on and lead fulfilling
challenging professional careers and my
bill my private member's bill which I'll
be introduced into Parliament next week
seeks to do something practically about
that it's not a contentious measure I
don't think it's something that the
previous Prime Minister David Cameron
was able to support and I hope that we
can work together
establish a cross-party consensus to say
it isn't acceptable in 2017 that we've
got four million children growing up in
poverty well in Barnsley I think about
one in five children is said to be
growing up in poverty what does that
actually mean for a child to be growing
up in poverty it means that it's much
harder for them to get on in life my
great frustration with our country is
that we've got huge potential or people
are amazing I'm always inspired when I
come to places like this school to meet
the children to talk about the
aspiration and the ambition that they
have but if you are growing up in
poverty it's much harder to do well at
school you don't have the same life
opportunities and let's be very clear
the kind of people that we are talking
about are those people that the Prime
Minister referred to as the just
managing often the kids that were
talking about who are growing up in
poverty have parents who are in
full-time work these are people who are
doing the right thing who are working
hard but at the end of each month or
struggling to make ends meet that's my
issue with what you're saying though is
that labor can only do anything about
this if they're in power and if you look
at the polls now right now it looks like
labour are unelectable we've lost two
general elections and we've lost them
quite badly and I want to make sure that
we don't lose another one so all of us
who believe in the value of labour
politics to achieve meaningful good for
communities like bonzi but around the
country as well have an absolute
responsibility to get involved to think
long and hard about why it was that the
public didn't feel that they could trust
us previously and to do the hard work
that you have to do in opposition if the
polls don't improve should Jeremy Corbyn
be considering his position I think that
we face a very significant challenge and
polls are bad they're good they sort of
they blow in the wind we've lost two
general elections none of us want to
lose a third one the leader in the end
has to take responsibility for the
direction of travel and the level of
progress that we are making I'm not sure
it's helpful for me to kind of get into
a running commentary about how higher
well that's going do you think that he'd
make a good Prime Minister politics is
so complex it's so fluid if we'd sat
here two years ago discuss
in Britain leaving the European Union a
president Trump in the White House David
Cameron Stanley now as the Prime
Minister these would all have come as
sort huge surprises so I think Jeremy
Corbyn has developed his his durability
he's won now twice and been elected as
the lead the Labour Party and on that
basis he deserves our loyalty and our
respect and he also deserves all of us
to get involved and to support the work
that he's doing to come up this analysis
of the challenges that the country faces
so in the end it's not whether I think
he baked make a good Prime Minister or
it's it's about the public they get to
decide and actually I think they're very
canny at making the decision and we've
got to convince them then when it comes
to the big issues like national security
like keeping the country safe and making
those really really difficult decisions
about the economy and safeguarding the
public finances can they place their
faith and trust in him and if he can
convince them that he can then that's a
great thing and that will be in a strong
position to win and we need to support
him in that process but none of us
should underestimate how difficult that
is going to be so Jeremy Corbyn the man
whose Rebels over 400 times against the
same party's whip is now imposing a
three-line whip on his own MPs
over article 50 is that the right thing
to do I think Jeremy is right on this
this is the biggest change that our
country faces and it is right that as a
Labour Party we come together we
establish a consensus amongst ourselves
so I think it is the right decision
absolutely acknowledge that for many
colleagues that will present a massive
choice that they have to make in the end
I'm sure people will vote with their
conscience and do what they think is the
right thing for their constituencies and
for their constituents but on such a
major issue such as this I think it is
the right thing for the leader to take a
view and to ensure that colleagues to an
extent are bound by that decision are
you voting for article 50 or thousand
yeah I think I've listened very
carefully to what people have said here
in my constituency 70% of my
constituents voted to leave the European
Union I think it is the right thing to
do to trigger article 50 and we begin
that process of negotiation but what
I'll be doing throughout that process is
scrutinizing the government and the
actions that they take and seeking to
ensure
we secure the best possible deal for my
constituents here in Yorkshire they
voted to leave the European Union but
nobody voted to be poorer you say it's
important for labour to show that you're
understanding people's concerns so
what's the party's policy now
immigration I think the party's policy
on immigration is do two things firstly
absolutely to recognise the benefits we
are economically better off because
people come here from within the
European Union and from other parts of
the world
to make an economic and a social and
cultural contribution so it is to
understand the benefits but it is also
to recognize the concerns and as a party
we can never Ford never afford to look
like we don't understand the concern
that minutes are particular do you think
you risk looking like that that you
don't understand yes I I do think that
for too long in the previous Parliament
and in this one as well we have run the
risk of demonstrating to people that we
don't understand the concerns that they
have it isn't racist to have concerns
about the impact that migration has on
our country and we need to demonstrate
that we're listening to those people who
do have genuine concerns who do believe
that immigration could be managed more
effectively in the interest of our
country we have to demonstrate to them
that we're listening and that we take
their concerns very seriously you've
clearly spent quite a lot of time
thinking about the future of labour that
issues like child poverty that you feel
very passionately about do you ever look
back and think I wish I'd run for Labour
leader would have had the chance I don't
think back I don't think back to that
moment very often because I'm quite busy
looking forward it's quite tough time to
be in politics I'm really sad that a
couple of my labour colleagues have
stood down but I don't think this is the
time to stand down I think it's the time
frankly to step up you know there are
huge challenges that we all face it
could be quite hard going but the truth
of the matter is serving in politics is
a great privilege